good afternoon everybody welcome to the
presentation
watching the watchers how surveillance
companies track you using mobile
networks
my name is calhoun mcdade i am cto of
adaptive mobile security
and what we do is we help mobile
operators around the world defend their
telecom networks
today i'll be taking you through the
world of mobile surveillance companies
as seen from our experience in detecting
and blocking them
i'll be explaining what they do how to
do it how they've changed over time
and what we can expect for them in the
future along with plenty of examples
and interestingly this is actually quite
a topical subject at the moment
surveillance companies are often in the
news but
these three headlines are all from this
month december
with which all covered roughly the same
area about how surveillance companies
are using mobile networks
and there have been many other headlines
in the previous months and years for
last few years
but before i jump in the details of the
surveillance companies
it's worth remembering how we got here
in the first place and why we are
discussing this
today almost every network around the
world uses the 2g
or the 3g network protocols and what
this
and how these networks work is they use
a protocol called signaling system 7 rss
7.
this is the backbone network which
allows mobile operators to communicate
within their network and between mobile
networks
and what allows you to roam when we used
to roam
send text messages abroad make phone
calls
be connected and so on and
as you are probably many you aware
there's been a lot of reports of
security incidents
with this over the last couple years and
these all
stem from one key assumption in
development of the sd7 network
a simply that assumes trust between
every mobile phone operator around the
world
the network was designed in a time when
everybody assumed that only those who
have access
should have access simply a trust model
and as it turns out this hasn't been the
case as there has been some connections
which have abused this trust
interestingly enough the protocol which
has replaced the 2g
3g network in many places the 4g network
also suffers from the same protocol this
protocol are same
problem this protocol is called diameter
and the same trust issue exists
in that it also assumes that everybody
who is connected
um should have access and will not do
anything malicious
so this is one small key takeaway often
is described that the problem with the
mobile phone networks is this age that
because it was developed in the 70s or
80s or 90s
it wasn't designed with security well a
protocol designed in 2010s
also has the same problem in fact it's
even slightly worse
so the problem itself isn't so much that
technology it's just the trust and the
security assumptions
in building the technology at the time
so keeping in mind the security
implications
we can now look to see who is actually
exploiting this trust model
well we see three main types of
explosives one there's fairness
companies who are speaking about haitian
second governments um here is a
screenshot from a report from the
ukrainian regulator
this is from 2014 and was one of the key
events in pushing the development of
signaling security this is a report
today issued concerning
um attacks or malicious activity which
she observed coming in
to their networks from what they believe
were russian sources in 2014
and finally of course on enough
unexpectedly criminals criminals we've
also seen exploiting these networks
there's some overlap between
surveillance companies and governments
as you might expect
governments are often to customers they
want to buy this equipment
from the surveillance companies but
sometimes governments may try to build
this technology themselves
rather than reliance variance companies
and when they do they often use some of
the same sources
as in entry points as arranged companies
we also see also small overlapping
criminal activity insurance companies
again
they sometimes there's an overlap in the
sources and how they gain access to
these networks
one important thing those failures
companies keep in mind is they have very
large resources they get paid a lot for
what they do
and this large resources translates into
complex
attacks and quite sophisticated
technologies and we'll see this as i go
in
more details about how attacks are
executed
so attacks and how to execute it is very
interesting point because it's not
always apparent exactly what is an
attack over these signal networks
first thing to keep in mind though is
that the industry is very different from
2014.
from 2014 we in the industry have been
recommending ways for mobile operators
to protect subscribers and their
networks
and the key outputs to this is series of
recommendations or standards or
documents if you will
for the 2g 3g network which is seven the
key document is a document called fs11
and for the 4g network which is a
protocol called diameter
the key output is a document called fs19
and so what the operators do
around the world is they take this
information and then they work with
mobile security companies like ourselves
or other vendors
to put in place protection again and
um firewalls and defenses based on these
recommendations
one particular thing to keep in mind
though is that this is just a starting
block so when they apply
in these recommendations they find that
a vast vast majority of traffic
vs7 traffic in this case is completely
normal
but there's a very small percentage in
this case 0.04
which we see which is irregular or
suspicious
very important thing to keep in mind
though is a regular
or suspicious does not necessarily equal
malicious
when you actually look at this 0.04
percent
traffic the vast vast majority of is
just noise
it's misconfigured uh nodes around the
world
uh local specific configurations and so
on the vast majority
is not actually malicious when you
investigate this in detail
as you we believe you have to do you
find then a very small percentage of
0.04 percent
1.37 is actually malicious
and this is an important point not
everything which you
an operator may block may actually
regard as malicious a lot of it just
noise which they are blocking
primarily to be safe and to be certain
and it can take a lot of experience
a lot it takes a lot of analysis to
determine what is malicious versus
what is simply irregular and it can be
quite easy to make mistakes
if you sometimes you read headlines of
huge attacks using
um ss7 arbor network many cases what's
happened here is that
um the the person analyzing may have
regarded all this type of traffic
malicious but that isn't the case
it's simply irregular in this report in
this presentation we have
focused primarily and in fact
exclusively on what we regard as
malicious
types of traffic
so looking at the traffic itself let's
look to see who generates this so
one question is obvious question mo what
do mobile surveillance companies do
and our experiences can you guess is
surveillance
and it primarily breaks into two main
areas when it comes to ss7 mobile's
fairness company spent
60 about most of their activity 60 of
their activity
harvesting information and then roughly
about half that again
spent about 30 doing the actual tracking
and i'll show you how that ratio often
shows up in real life attacks
soon they also spend a certain amount of
time as well doing
um testing as well as that to spend a
small percentage of time to actually
interception of calls and
text messages you may expect that to be
larger but that is the next
case the vast majority of time
surveillance companies are doing
tracking
or they're doing information harvesting
and the reason for the information
harvesting is simply to help to location
tracking
this is as i mentioned ss7 activity
which is the 3g
2g network but for the 4g network they
also use this protocol call diameter i
haven't shown that
in these stats here their malicious
activity over
diameter has been quite small in the
past but we have seen a large increase
in it recently
and for one picture of surveillance
company we do see
also ss7 activity or sorry sms activity
and i'll go into more detail about that
soon
so how look how is location tracking
done via seven
well first of all if you want to get
more public
background information i really
recommend you go to to
take a look at two excellent
presentations from an earlier edition of
this chaos computer club 31c
and that's from carson nolan twice
angled angle and they gave a very good
overview of how these attacks are
executed but from a high level
there's two different ways of doing this
a direct method
where an attacker will query a node
called the hlr
the attacker will send in a full number
which is a missing and get back a cell
id
or an indirect method where the attacker
will first
use the phone number to get some
background information in this case the
mznc
and then uses information to query no
deeper in the network directly
to get back the same information the
cell id
these two parts of these attacks the
first part of the main part of
method one and the second part of the
meta two are the location tracking part
but this in part beforehand in meta two
is called the information harvesting
now you may ask why does the attacker do
this at all
why should we use meta2 when a method
one is more direct
well this is because things change
mobile operators
are putting in defenses analysis a lot
harder to do method one
surveillance companies have essentially
a toolbox of commands that they can use
then there's three main commands that
they can use in the ss7 network
ati psi and psl which stand for the
information in the table here and from
their perspective their pros and cons
and using each of these commands
and their primary pros and cons of
decision making point
is often down to what's what will work
in the operator that they are targeting
me and this is mainly based on what
defenses the operator has
so to show this uh diagrammatically
we can show this graph here and here
i've plotted out and the axis is
two main pieces of information and the
bottom axis is the possibility of this
attack
to be blocked and on the
left axis the vertical axis the amount
of information that an attacker needs
to have to be successful and you can see
these three previous commands
be spread out like this
this is the it shows the amount
information which an attacker might
need on the left and like i said on the
bottom the possibility attacker three
blocked
where an attacker really wants to be is
in the bottom left segment because
here it's more likely that their attack
will be successful or less likely to be
blocked and they need to give
best information so
we can see that the ati there the
possibility of it being blocked is quite
high
but the amount of information that the
attacker needs is quite low it just
needs a phone number
whereas the psi in the top left the
amount information attacker needs is
high it needs phone number and more
details and but the possibility attacker
to be blocked is less again
so you can see there's a distribution
and there are choices to be made by an
attacker
i'll show those choices and how a real
life attack actually occurs
here is a real life attack from march
2018.
in this picture case are several stages
of the attack
first of all there's an information
harvesting part of it and this point in
time
we've seen we saw two attacks two
packets come in from
two sources in the uk channel islands
these are two operators
stuart guernsey and jersey airtel and
these are uses command called srism this
is a standard
information harvesting type method
then there was another information
harvesting using two different other
types of packets these
confusingly look very similar but they
do slightly different things
again from the same sources then we saw
a third
series of information harvesting again
two sri sams from the united kingdom
but one also packet as well from
cameroon
and then finally at this point we saw
the actual location tracking attack
here we see four atis one from jersey
airtel
and then one from cameroon israel now
it's important to note in this
particular case
that all these attacks were actually
blocked by the operator
so no information we was retrieved and
the atis at the awards end was more an
element of desperation from the attacker
also this is all within a five minute
period so you can see the the
sequence of attacks is relatively quick
between all five
in this particular case the attacker was
in quite
a hurry has wives in a hurry and the
actual target
well this is actually what occurred
we subsequently learned that the
targeted mobile number
was associated with this person herve
jober
who was a french formal naval officer
and marine engineer
and the aim we believe of the attack was
to see if the number existed
and if so its location this is a video
of the nostromo a bullsh
which was being believed this person was
on at the time
and there's quite a bit of discussion
about on the events geopolitical events
around this case
in this article and for more details i
encourage you to go link to get the
complete story of what has actually
occurred around this time
so that is the ss7 network but now let's
look at to see how it happens in other
networks particularly the 4g network
which uses the diameter protocol
this is very very similar again there
can be a direct method in which case the
attacker can use a command called udr
and then they retrieve from the hss as a
cell id
or an indirect method and in this case
there's nothing to stop the attacker
using an earlier packet from an earlier
protocol in this case seven
to get the information because this is
simply the information harvesting part
of the phase
so assuming that they do this they
harvest information using this command
at the time
they can then use this information using
an idr command
and then retrieve the cell id from the
network targeted network again two
methods
location tracking is the key part to
receive information but information
harvesting
is really the prerequisite piece of
information that needs to happen
when the attack when the targets network
starts putting in protection
so again there's a toolbox of commands
that the subscriber can use
and as you kind of guess each one of
these commands also has
pros and cons on whether it can be
used successfully or not
so to show that again visually with the
same graph
and i recreate again the three commands
which you saw earlier for ss7
if i plot these three diameter commands
we can actually see that they
occupy some of the same or similar
positions as the s7 commands
the two in the bottom right plr udr
these are type attacks that a an
attacker would want to use in ideal
world
because they require less information
but
these are much more likely that an
operator will successfully block from
the start
so many cases what the attacker ends up
having to use is a command called an idr
which is in the top left they need a lot
more information for this to be
successful
but it's harder for an operator to
actually block this
so what these look like in
real life so this is a real idr command
which we saw actually just a few weeks
ago
and in this particular case the command
is insert subscriber data idr
and where is this coming from just to
keep the team going this is actually
originated
from a network this originated from
jersey air throttle network
again
and the destination of this is
a first of all a subscriber
a username and a destination network
somewhere in
this region this is g in mobile country
called geography region 5
is asia pacific region and in this
particular case they're requesting their
current location
so there is no reason why a
network in the chat license should be
requesting the cell id
of a subscriber who is in one of these
networks but this is what we actually
see in this case and this is a location
track and request
over diameter
i'm showing again the channel islands
but there's multiple networks for
sources of these attacks
which can happen as we see over diameter
so one important thing to know is that
i've shown you 3g and i've shown you 4g
but this
surveillance companies don't necessarily
think in the world that way
they see mobile technology as the tool
not as a patch
so to recap a surveillance company they
want to target
their targets obviously so what we've
seen over time is that they can execute
ss7 attacks using the 3g protocol what
can happen then is the mobile operator
will start putting in place protection
and bill puts in firewalls to prevent
these actual types of attacks
then over time the surveillance company
might switch to 4g
to use the diameter protocol and again
what will happen eventually is the
mobile operator put in place defenses
to block these types of attacks
so what you might expect in future then
is maybe that the
surveillance company might use variance
of these attacks different ways of doing
it or eventually might use to
move to the 5g protocol and again our
mobile operator
will put in place firewalls and we just
got to protect the wall to protect us
now it will be brilliant if the world
works like this but surveillance
companies don't think
in a linear path from their perspective
all they care about is the target they
don't care what technology they use and
they are not
beholden to development plans and
technology schedules they just want to
get information on the target
so in this particular case what happens
if they can get
sources of their attacks within the
network
then that becomes a very valuable
temperament thing for them to aim for
and a very valuable tool for them to use
and this is what we've seen with this
next type of attack which we've seen the
attackers use
this is attack we call sim jacker and
this is why it's so valuable in that
allowed them to essentially bypass
the plans and the top processes
of the industry in defending against
surveillance companies
using mobile technologies
so to step back a moment what exactly is
sim jacker
um it's essentially a vulnerability
which we reported
last year 2019 and what it is is uses a
vulnerability in a sim card
library the sim card library is called
the sat browser does pronounce
sat or sap browser and the problem with
the sap browser is it did not
validate or authorize any source sms
that it received
so this vulnerability then could be
exploited by text messages and once
a text message was sent with sap browser
commands in it
it then was allowed access to a subset
of what are called sim toolkit commands
which are on the mobile device
um we issued a very detailed reportness
over 40 page
technical report which is free online
from www.simjack.com which i recommend
you to read
but we found when we analyzed this that
this vulnerability was present at
several hundred million sim cards around
the world
and we could see and i'll show you
examples that was actively exploited in
these three countries
in latin america we shared a cbd
coordinated vulnerability disclosure
within the mobile industry
mid last year we reported some
information 2019 before giving more
technical information october 2019
that staggered approach was to give time
for mobile operators to put in place
defenses
and to see if they were actually
affected or not and the key thing about
sim jacker is
one it was a huge increase in complexity
it was the first recorded spyware
actually sent within an sms there has
been some rumors and reports from
leaks from the nsa of this type of
capability but this has never actually
been seen before in real life
but as well as this it was also a huge
increase in capability
and allowed one surveillance company in
particular
to do a lot more than what they have
been doing in the past and possibly to
achieve a lot more results and to offer
new services to their customers
so the flow of how this actually works
so in this particular case his friend's
company to do a sim tracker attack they
don't need ss7 access
they don't need to buy expensive
commitment they don't need to buy links
all they need is a mobile device
they send this mobile device they are
sorry they take this mobile device and
they just
send simply send a text message with a
series of commands
in it to their target this text message
is then forwarded on to the target and
is received by the device
when the device receives that text
message it actually gives it to the sim
card
within the device and then the sim card
takes over and this is where the term
sim jacker
came from the sim card will then
instruct the device
to provide information in this
particular case
uh cell id and this information is sent
back to the sim card
the stem character also requests a bunch
of other information as well such as the
type of device
and more attributes but once all this
information is received
the sim card will then instruct the
device
to send out a text message this case
then
the device will send this text message
directly back
to the surveillance company and their
mobile handset
so there is a seven used in the fact
that all s
but there's no need for expensive access
there's no need to
try to gain or try to avoid ss7
firewalls or diameter firewalls
they're simply using text messages here
to initiate and do the attacks
so this is the location tracking part of
the
part of the command but in fact the
whole the whole
sequence from start to finish is a whole
location tracking
phase
again if you want more information about
this i really encourage you to check out
the paper on steamjacker.com because it
goes in far more detail about this
i've shown here this is a method one
sent from handset extract to handset
the surveillance company use many
different methods sometimes they extract
it to an ss7 node sometimes they send
from other types of links
and use multiple meta to try to avoid
defenses
but this is in this most basic shows you
how they actually executed this attack
again toolbox of commands that the
attacker actually use
um degrading from the attacker's
perspective here
they're pros they don't require any ss7
access
all they required is a phone number the
phone number of the target
now the con also from their perspective
is that they needed to have
the destination the victims
handset to have a sim card with this
browser on it
your sim cards vast majority european
sim cards
don't have this this library under on
their sim card
um it was a certain percentage when we
analyzed it was several hundred million
that's a conservative number but not
every sim card around the world
has this um vulnerable library on it
so that was a particular con that they
have and also sometimes
not often but sometimes some operators
put in place
security around that so the default
deployment of this of the library was
vulnerable but sometimes
some operators have made some changes to
make it non-vulnerable so this is a con
from obviously from the operator from
the attacker's perspective
in that not every mobile device around
the world had this library presence
so if i'm to take my grid again and
the deployment and sorry the
distribution of these attacks
if i can say that ss7 is distributed
this way
and then diameter is distributed this
way
one way of visualizing a sim jacker
attack is very much
in the bottom left quadrant because the
possibility for it to be blocked
is actually quite low it requires
specific logic
and algorithms which most operators may
not have had in place
and the amount of information that it
required was very very low
again all it required is a phone number
that asterisk is of course though on the
presumption
that the targeted number had
a sim card which had a sap browser
present on it
so if there was no sap browser present
the target sim then it wouldn't be valid
so now i'm going to go into details
about a particular attack
i just want no before going examples in
this one the vast majority of sim jacker
attacks which we saw were sent
from a handset to another handset as in
i would target an attacker with target
you
and once your phone registered it would
send it back to a handset which would be
um
normally within that network but
sometimes what we saw is that they were
trying to extract
via a ss7 address
and this is the case i'm showing here
but essentially this is a
attack we saw a few months ago
the destination is a mexican phone phone
number
it is coming the message has been sent
from a mexican
mobile as well so this is a mobile to a
mobile or handset to a handset
type of attack
and here we can see the actual payload
the sdk protocol indicates this is the
sap browser payload and within it is
requesting a series of information
to one that have highlighted here is
requesting location information
but it's also requesting imei
information which the exact type of the
actual handset
once all this information is received
there's a concatenate command you see
there and that means it all puts it into
a blob and then this blob is sent
outwards
and it is sent outwards using the send
short message command so this command
instructs the handset to send out
another text message
with all the information which has been
received and this information will be
sent
to a ss7 address which is again is
registered in sure currency
and for those keeping track that's
actually the same
as s7 addresses we call it a global
title as
the attack which i showed in the ss7
example
and this type of information is quite
useful for us sometimes to do
correlation
and association of different types of
attacks
you can probably see this looks quite
complex and
it's a certainly a more sophisticated
type of attack than what we see over
a seven hour even diameter and a lot of
work a lot of effort has gone into
putting together
these types of attacks what it does do
is it really opens up the
the avenues for the attacker because
like i said they don't need ss7 access
for this
in my particular case once we um
reverse engineered these types of
attacks it was quite a
sobering concept to realize that i was
able to i had the ability myself
to track potentially several hundred
million people
using text messages just by just by
using text messages
and this is before these mobile
operators put in place detection and
blocking of these attacks
so certainly a very very powerful
technique
so stepping back a moment and going back
to
to generalities i've shown you the sim
jacker type of attack well
we ask ourselves how does sim jacker
rate to ss7
so this is data from the end of 2019
and the start of 2020 the second half of
2019 the start of 2020 and from specific
operators
um between eight to ten mobile operators
we've taken data from
and these by the way are all attacks
which have been blocked
but we can see that the vast majority of
attacks we've
seen are being used in ss7 roughly two
thirds and then one third
of surveillance types of tracking
attacks we've seen using sim jacker
type techniques
now like i said according to our
intelligence only one surveillance
company uses sim checker
but the but the reason why the sim
jacker volumes is actually so high
is that we've one or two specific
operators where the volumes are huge but
the volumes of sim jack attacks are huge
and these are skewing
somewhat or overall statistics to show
you this if we were to show you the
stats from one particular
operator or i call it operator a in that
particular case
the vast vast majority of at location
tracking attacks which we see
have been executed using sim checker
which is sms and only a small percentage
15 percent has been executed uses ss7
and believe it or not this is much
smaller number of sim jacker attacks now
than it was in the past
prior to public announcement and prior
to
us put in place active detection and
blocking of these attacks
the ratio was much much higher many many
times higher
in that the volumes of location tracking
attacks using sim jacker were absolutely
enormous was many many times
higher
this diameter attacks might be
surprising but
we see quite a small very small
percentage
up until the last six months of diameter
attacks
but somewhat surprising to me and
possibly a shape of things government
last six months being a large escalation
of
diameter attacks and i haven't shown the
armor attacks in these stats but in
future reports
we can show them
so going back to the sim jacker versus
s7 distribution
we and i'll show you why a work interior
that we have
behind this um obviously mismatch
between software
certain operators is that they're
different we believe that there's
different
end users to different types of end
users for these surveillance companies
and this could be best probably shown
with the following graph
so we're all aware unfortunately due to
covet of of rates per 100 thousands
so to building this what i've done here
is to try to show a distribution
of location tracking attempts per 100
000 subscribers
in in one year so this is a way to show
an
easy reference the rate of tracking per
operator because some operators are much
bigger than others
and as a result if we showed the exact
volumes the actual numbers become very
skewed
but you can actually see here it's
actually quite standard
i've shown nine operators here and the
ss7 location tracking activity
normally ranges between 150
to maybe 50 location tracking temps per
100 000 subscribers
so this seems quite standard and it
seems like uh
quite well or quite evenly distributed
but the interesting thing if i start to
add in sim jacker activity
we see in one particular operator that
the
amount of observed sim jack or location
tracking is
huge brings it up to roughly about 400
times
and this is actually with us doing this
detecting and blocking
so when we go and detect and block these
attacks we actually disturbed the system
it's not like schrodinger's cat but it's
basically our act of observing and
blocking this
has caused the system to go out of
equilibrium we believe from our
estimates from analysis
prior to us doing this detection
blocking
that this was the extent of the
sim jacker type activity up to over 1200
location tracking times per 100 000
subscribers
and we've less regular evidence but
something we're trying to firm up in
fact we believe in another operator it
was actually even higher
it's even up to around 2000 or possibly
2 000
above location tracking attempts for 100
000 subscribers
so you can see that the actual
usage of it was much much higher in
these operators
in this particular operator and the
reason why we think
and what this gives us a few conclusions
is that
we could say at least from what we've
observed is that ss7
the 3g and 2g 3g protocol is not
normally used for bulks or subscriber
tracking at least by surveillance
companies
but certainly sim jacker was or is
it was that technology which was
developed and used to bulk
tracking of subscribers
and this was one key reason as to why we
found sim jacker
why we tossed himself was so important
in that it really introduced a new way
for
surveillance companies to and new use
cases for them to potentially offer
so something that we want to see other
trends over time
this is probably also interesting for
some this is the trends of s7 location
tracking commands over time
so we can see in 2016 ati which
if you can remember is the blue color
that's the one that we said that it's
probably the
easiest one for the surveillance
companies but it's also
the easier one for mobile operators to
block so the volumes of that have
decreased a lot from 2016
and then other commands psl which sort
of midway
that had a growth in popularity between
2016 2017
and now it's really drowned after around
2019.
psi on the other hand has increased and
has been quite as steady and that is the
one that is
hardest for the for the attacker to use
they would certainly prefer not to use
it because it
doesn't always work but it's the one
which the only ones which they may have
any success with anymore or they feel
they have any success like i said these
are all blocked commands
one interesting point is you may see two
new um
colors here um
this is one called ati and provide psi
and you may say this is the exact same
command what actually is happening here
is that the attackers have done a
variant they've tried to
basically disguise these commands
they're trying to give these commands a
new lease of life
and they're using a a new sort of
potential vulnerability called global op
code
if you want more information this i also
recommend you check out this
presentation from positive technologies
from hack in the box
in may 2019 but essentially what the
attackers do is that they try to bypass
protection in place and if this works
this gives them a new lease of life
in the ati command because then they
come back to using their favorite ati
command
and this time he may try to be able to
bypass any defenses that are in place
so one question that we often get asked
is how do these surveillance companies
gain access to the s7 network
sometimes that is closely followed by
and how do i gain access to the ssm
network
which is i being the person who is
asking me this question
so there's multiple methods and
a lot of this comes down to intelligence
and research but primarily there's
three main methods which are the most
common and one as you can guess is that
they pay for the link
and this can be quite nebulous and very
hard sometimes to track down but often
they will have if
they will set up these friends companies
might set up a front company
who then negotiate access to other
companies who may resell access to
mobile operators so there might be
multiple links here
and multiple layers of who's selling
access to whom
this is still not guaranteed to work for
them but often works best for them in
jurisdictions areas which may have poor
regulations or oversight
are are companies who
may not investigate too thoroughly what
these companies are doing once they get
access many cases they may
get access to use for one technique are
for legitimate services
and then after a month or two start to
switch to use other services which are
malicious
the second method which they may use to
gain access
is to use big rudder governments like
i said are the customers of these
surveillance solutions
so what they may man do is their mandate
the system might be installed in the
captive operator
um or else to add directly onto link by
passing the operator completely
in this case then the operator may have
has very little say in a matter
they've been told they installed this
system or in some
a lot of countries around the world the
operators might have direct connections
to the to the backbone network and they
can add directly onto link
this is less common than pain for the
link method but it can actually happen
and finally something that's quite rare
nowadays at least is all legacy
connections
default companies whose access is not
completely removed
this is much rarer because on the s7
network
every every packet has to be paid by
somebody so it's very
unusual to have access to a network and
nobody's charging you first
uh it's also less of an issue in
diameter than ss7
but it was present in the past and it
happened there's also
less common ways that operators may
already surveillance companies but get
access but
i'm not going to go into detail in this
presentation
one particular thing though is quite
quite interesting
is that first of all as you can guess
the pricing of the access is not
very opaque but from our analysis we can
see that normally between
it costs between two to ten cent
per message necessarily unit that are
sent but it's
very much that the more connections the
more access that
that a surveillance company has over the
ss7 diameter network
the much more valuable it is because
this means if somebody's get blocked
or get detected it still has backup
still different ways to send
attacks so it's very much in these
surveillance companies
interest to have as many as much access
as possible as distributed as possible
this also leads to some rather bizarre
business cases when you come across
these this here is a graph
from an ss7 tracking company or
purported s7 tracking company and the
prices that they advertised
on the web and this is really much
the opposite of what you would expect
from a if you were an economics
student because there was no economies
at scale here
they were actually charging more the
more you try to track and not less
which is quite unusual but then it makes
sense if you consider what they're doing
the more that you try to track the more
that you'll be drawing attention to
yourself
and therefore the more likely that the
link would be disconnected and they
would lose their entire business
so from their perspective it's worth
more to charge
you more because they are taking higher
and higher risk
and not charge you less even though
you're using up you're actually paying
for more
so it's sort of an inverse what you
expect and like i said
not really economies of scale type
approach
so this is surveillance companies today
but also we want to talk about 5g
and mobile experience companies
now i can guarantee you the 5g networks
will be targeted for use by these mobile
surveillance companies
and again like i said it starts you know
age is the number
and this just for case newer does not
always equal better
the 5g network does solve many security
problems on
on mobile networks especially on the
radio side and does make improvements to
some of the core network side
but it also introduces new risks and new
and new
potential problems well for a start it's
it's more complex
and anything that's more complex
inevitably may have
more potential vulnerabilities to show
you how much more complex
here's a graph of the 4g network versus
the 5g network when it comes to protocol
complexity
you can see it's many multiples of times
more complex
both on the number of messages which
could be sent that's on the bottom axis
and within those messages how many
different elements and if you consider
each one of those elements may have to
be individually inspected and checked
this can make things much more complex
when it comes to trying to defend
these networks as well as that the 5g
networks have
new concepts like slicing uh mixed
networks
and 5g networks talking to 4g networks
talking to networks
so a lot of moving parts which
could mean which will mean and are areas
that mobile surveillance companies will
try to exploit
so one good thing at least this time is
that
unlike 3g and 4g within the industry we
are
now defining security from the start for
the 5g networks
it's always much easier to put in place
security from the start than try to
reverse engineer
in security but one key thing we have to
keep
thinking keep in mind there's the
difference between
it and mobile network security we
already know
in 3g and 4g that vast majority attacks
come from
no legitimate entities they come in from
the ss7 network
so unlike possibly it where you can just
block off
certain ip addresses or sources
there's no way one operator can block
off another content or off in another
country
so you do have to accept that you are
going to be targeted
and attacked and so you need to put
interface defenses to detect within
those flows what's going on
and for a good discussion about this and
why 5g
in itself won't solve a lot of those
issues please see this blog
i wrote in the gsma which covered
the issuance of a new document a new
series of recommendations within gsma
on 5g internet security
so finally the toolbox and 5g starts to
get very very complicated
four commands here i won't go into too
much details again there's going to be
pros and cons for the attacker
unfortunately is when as well they also
get multiple new ways to get location
they can
sign up for events and subscriptions so
it's going to get quite complex
and there's going to be a lot of work
required to detect and block these
attacks and try to stop these various
companies
again with this grid of my previous
attacks 3g
2g 3g 4g and sim jacker
if i add in the 5g commands things get
quite complicated but these are
my estimations of the distribution of
these some of these commands are quite
interesting
especially c on a square pl
but time will tell if these
distributions are correct
and how often are what the attackers
will try to use them
and how when they will try to use them
so i've covered a huge amount of
information here in this presentation
and thank you we've come to the end of
it but there's a few key takeaways i
want you to take and some key
conclusions that we could take
from this presentation
as you can guess and as i've shown you
experience companies they do exploit
mobile signal networks today
um but they're not static they adjust
techniques based on defenses and end
users
um if you start to read articles about
ss7 it could be wide open that is
not the case for the vast majority
operators operators are doing things
um it's also at the same time the
surveillance companies are also making
changes as well to also avoid
these defenses that are put in place
another key point in 5g networks is that
they are not invulnerable
um if somebody says that 5g networks is
fully secure then that is not true
there will be opportunities for defense
companies and they will definitely try
to use it because like i said
surveillance companies don't care about
technology path they care about it
well they don't care about the target
but they care about getting information
about the target
and they will use whatever technologies
that they can
and again mobile operators they can and
many do
detect and block attacks and the key to
do this is
intelligence and when our from our
perspective
the key thing is that like many types of
security you can't just press a button
and walk away from it you have to
actually look after it
and tell look use your intelligence
investigate because these surveillance
companies
have huge resources and they will make
efforts to bypass
and go around any type of defenses that
you have in place
and then comes back to the team this
presentation you know why are we doing
this analysis well the reason we do this
type of analysis
is because if you kind of see what is
going on you cannot conceivably stop it
in the future
so watching the watchers as well as
being interesting is also critical
from a security perspective because the
more you know about what they are doing
the better you are able to detect them
and block them
thank you very much for listen this
presentation
i've only scratched the surface of
surveillance companies and their use
of mobile networks but i hope you found
this information useful
and i look forward to taking your
questions now